je les bougeais comme j'aurais voulu
que mes propres bras et jambes soient bougés
s'ils avaient dû rester immobiles chaque heure de la journée.
Je me souviens avoir serré ses doigts près de mon visage,
massant chaque articulation pour qu'ils restent souples et flexibles.
Et je lui ai demandé encore et encore,
de visualiser le mouvement,
de regarder de l'intérieur le doigt se courber
s'étendre et se déplacer dans son esprit.
Puis, un jour, du coin de l’œil,
j'ai vu son corps bouger comme un serpent,
un spasme involontaire passait à travers ses membres.
Au début, j'ai cru que j'hallucinais,
ayant passé tant de temps à m'occuper de son corps,
guettant désespérément n'importe quelle réaction.
Mais il m'a dit avoir ressenti des picotements,
des étincelles électriques qui s'illuminent et s'éteignent
juste sous la surface de sa peau.
Les semaines suivantes, il a commencé très légèrement
à montrer une résistance des muscles.
Les connexions s'établissaient.
Le corps commençait doucement et tendrement à se réveiller,
membre par membre, muscle par muscle,
spasme par spasme.
Étant photographe documentaire,
j'ai resenti le besoin de capturer
chacun de ses premiers mouvements
comme une mère avec son nouveau-né.
J'ai photographié sa première respiration libre,
le moment de célébration après avoir montré
une résistance musculaire pour la première fois,
les nouvelles technologies adaptées qui lui ont permis
de retrouver plus d'autonomie.
J'ai photographié l'attention et l'amour qui l'entouraient.
Mais mes photos racontaient seulement l'extérieur de l'histoire
d'un homme sur le lit d'un hôpital
relié à un appareil respiratoire.
Je ne pouvais pas décrire son histoire de l'intérieur,
alors j'ai commencé à chercher un nouveau langage visuel,
un langage qui pourrait exprimer la qualité éphémère
de son expérience spirituelle.
Pour finir, je veux partager avec vous
une vidéo d'une série sur laquelle j'ai travaillé
qui essaie de d'exprimer la lente existence « entre deux mondes »
que mon père a expérimentée.
Lorsqu'il a commencé à retrouver sa capacité à respirer,
j'ai enregistré ses pensées,
alors la voix que vous entendez dans cette vidéo est la sienne.
(Vidéo) Ronnie Cahana : Tu dois croire
que tu es paralysé
pour jouer le rôle
d'un tétraplégique.
Ce n'est pas mon cas.
Dans mon esprit
et dans mes rêves,
chaque nuit,
Je flotte comme Chagall-man
au-dessus-de la ville,
je déambule et je tournoie,
mes orteils embrassant le sol.
Je ne connais rien à l'état
d'un homme sans mouvement.
Chaque chose bouge.
Le cœur bat.
Le corps lutte.
La bouche bouge.
On ne stagne jamais.
La vie a des hauts et des bas. »
Pour la plupart d'entre nous,
nos muscles commencent à convulser et à bouger
longtemps avant d'en être conscient,
mais mon père m'a dit que son privilège,
c'est de vivre à la périphérie lointaine de l'expérience humaine.
Comme un astronaute qui voit une perspective
que peu d'entre nous peuvent partager,
il s'émerveille et regarde alors qu'il prend son premier souffle
et rêve de rentrer chez lui.
Ainsi commence la vie à 57 ans, dit-il.
Un bébé n'a aucune attitude dans son existence,
mais un homme sollicite le monde chaque jour.
Peu parmi nous aurons à faire face à des contraintes physiques
de l'ampleur de celles subies par mon père,
mais nous aurons tous des moments de paralysie
dans nos vies.
Je sais que j’affronte fréquemment des obstacles
qui semblent infranchissables,
mais mon père insiste pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas de chemin sans issue.
Il m'invite plutôt dans son espace de co-guérison,
pour que je donne le meilleur de moi-même,
et pour qu'il puisse me donner le meilleur de lui-même.
La paralysie a été un commencement pour lui.
C’était l'occasion d'émerger,
de raviver la force de la vie,
de rester suffisamment avec lui-même
pour tomber amoureux de tout le continuum
de la création.
Aujourd’hui, mon père n’est plus paralysé.
Il bouge son cou aisément,
il se nourrit sans sonde,
il respire par ses propres poumons,
parle lentement par sa propre voix
et travaille chaque jour
pour retrouver plus de mouvements dans son corps paralysé.
Mais le travail ne sera jamais terminé.
Comme il dit : « Je vis dans un monde cassé,
et il y a tant à faire. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)